did you just give a half a million
dollars to the fiery fires in Malibu
your house destroyed yeah
and you have like a menagerie of animals
you guys what seven dogs yeah how many
horses I have now two horses uh that are
big size and I have too many we had two
pigs too many horses too big horses yeah
so what happens when a fire is going
down well actually like Liam I've never
loved him more for this this is your boy
yes he got me yeah kind of yeah ish
weird part my partner I call him my
survival partner now I think it's not
romantic but I learned that it is that's
is why you pair up with someone is for
survival and he was so incredible he got
all the animals out in his truck he put
two pigs in crates which I tell you is
all right I think you got him yes I said
how did you get them out and he said the
only thing I could do was get a really
powerful hose and sprayed them and they
asked so he just chased the pigs in to
save their life which was genius and
actually I was kind of glad that I
wasn't there because I think the thing
that got a lot of people in trouble was
you know in California we have fires all
the time and it's it's a little cry wolf
sometimes because you don't know when
it's actually gonna get you and I think
that you think there's no way this could
actually happen to me Neil Young lost
his house right yeah and I was thinking
about that too because I was thinking
that just that my age and the amount of
songs that I've written and that was the
hardest thing for me to for me to lose
was every song including Malibu I lost
because I always write it on paper oh
you mean in the Malibu house was my song
writing book that I wrote the lyrics and
bar so that's gone and so I was thinking
about these artists and even one entry
man save the book for Christ's sake that
was about the guy said what do you guys
like my laptop and my camera but the
good thing about that was is I actually
had a lot of physical pictures that
obviously you lose it's really hard and
so I'm glad he grabs the computer so he
castle in a fire you saved the animals
what you got to do first
yeah then he got his camera yeah then he
got his computer yes and then he had to
go deal with my cats are so stupid they
he tried to get the cats out but he was
kind of trying to lead them to the truck
because he had the dogs and all these
things and one of the cats started
running
put them in a they just he the cats have
never really been outside and I think he
started opening the door trying to get
them in and out and the one cat just ran
away and and I'm so glad that he didn't
just say okay you don't know what you're
running into and got them because I like
this yeah he's really he's really crying
yeah I mean the little action for saving
out oh he did yeah you got a lot I was
gonna say when do you even have time
together we had we had to make sure he
knew I was very very